jeringas cucharas filtros torniquetes en
esta sala adaptada en parís los adictos
pueden drogarse con menos riesgos
gracias a un material esterilizado
que saca a la gente de la calle es mejor
que la gente consuma de un espacio
seguro todos acá dicen cuando empiezan a
venir que consumen menos porque se
sienten más tranquilos cada día la sala
acoge más de 300 usuarios
kamel ha acudido regularmente desde la
apertura en menos riesgos si tienes una
sobredosis están acá siempre es útil
incluso cuando llevas años usando drogas
sigue cometiendo errores
en 2016 el barrio se había movilizado
contra el establecimiento del centro de
inyección seguro cinco años más tarde
ciertos vecinos siguen viendo su cierre
esto lleva a peleas agresiones
inseguridad por no hablar de las
jeringas utilizadas que se encuentran en
el suelo cerca de los niños para mí
estas estructuras tienen que quedarse
lejos de las viviendas de las escuelas
de los jardines infantiles frente a las
agrupaciones de adictos en parís dos
diputados han encontrado usuarios y
vecinos y han visitado la sala de
consumo justa hemos visto que es un
dispositivo eficaz en dos condiciones
ging por un lado que estas personas
estén integradas a una atención médica y
social más completa y con el objetivo de
frenar el consumo y por otro lado que la
implantación de esta sala sea concertada
con las autoridades sanitarias las
fuerzas del orden pero también los
vecinos sólo si la fifa
el gobierno francés acaba de anunciar la
creación de dos salas cada año una
decisión que podría generar controversia